that's what we enough to get a thumbnail
sketch pen in here and let's do the
straight forward pass first we're gonna
end up with a graph where we go okay so
that's why getting the derivatives first
sweet awesome enormous enough about the
graph the first three bit is these are
these you can read this off for me right
what happens the very good
we don't happen to the X just like a
regular power comes down etc either the
X just stays completely unfazed this
differentiation happens random
differentiate one more time and of
course what happens to the one it gets
differentiated away and you just get
dealt with this guy okay so far so good
okay now we want to have a look at the
next part which shares deduce that the
curve is concave down for all values of
X hmm
Concannon tells us that which driven is
okay it's this one yeah and you can see
me I give it to me right so for Part B I
would say EDX is greater than 0 for all
real values of x by the way as it's in
transitions we'll know it's actually
pretty completely important that we'd
say things like the values of expert
yeah are actually not even X that can
make this not positive so every we're
interested on the Cartesian plane e to
the X is above the axis you guys know
exactly what looks like right so since
that is the case negative e to the X
will have the opposite side yes like
I've just drawn this conclusion straight
from this I've flipped the direction and
that of course is what I've already
determined for the
so in other words concave down for this
domain which I've already stated or
revised of it yeah
well what did she is there's nothing
it's really different to what I'm saying
and what you said however I would like
something like this I would particularly
like some kind of reference to what the
actual second review is because like
suppose I don't know anything about the
exponential graph right suppose I
actually don't know this fact I could
kind of conclude this just by reading
the question like and not actually
demonstrating yeah yeah I know it this
is the case because it's a particular
kind of function so I think this is
probably you know I didn't mean it like
that but we're making it I do it for a
particular function so I hear it's
important okay
what does Paseos we're looking for a
maximum which derivative is that about
first you you're very good because the
first duty will tell us potential time
or try to tell us where the stationary
points are and we can work out on the
train station so therefore I'll say
potential turning points
because remember what I'm about to say
it doesn't guarantee attorney boy
catches a stationary military when the
first derivative is zero I already know
what the first rate of it is so I'll
just tidy things up a BX equals 1 so X
takes on what value it's just you right
yeah how I answer the question I have
not answer the question I found out what
value X might give me an actual maximum
but really no right so I should test
I should tell it's pretty easy isn't it
yes yes exactly so you can see it's
always concave down right everywhere
along the graph I just found a
stationary point it must fit into this
scheme the only kind of stationary point
that's concave down he's under customer
right so I would just say see it's fine
happy since
right since that's already the case and
it's concave down x equals zero is a
maximum or it's where a maximum because
now all I need is one what's the actual
value what is the value it's negative
one isn't it infinite zero takeaway e to
the zero which is the maximum
now pump up
sorry every citizen oh we get to graph
now we have to grab now you already know
a bit about this yeah
x-rays EDX you know it's concave down
everywhere you know the highest-valued
that it takes okay Jori set of axes
you're only gonna need the maybe a pop
we copied your plane because of what I
just established although you have a
second to see what let's have a look
what we know about this thing
it's kind of funny you want you draw
your graph you know that this is the
highest you can pose we go ahead it's
concave down so you poke your intercept
on there you know it's turning points so
I've drawn my horizontal line in there
so the way I draw this graph I make sure
that I hit the horizontal at that point
cuz that's what your table should do and
I think what else do I know about this
okay
now are you gonna show you this a couple
of times because there's lots of
information you know that's just hidden
in plain sight
okay I'm clearly something's going on
with the gradient and this this will
tell me what's going on I just need to
think about what's happening to the left
and what's happening to the right okay
so for instance if I take the limit as X
approaches well let's have a look at the
left hand side the gun that's negative
infinity okay
as X approaches negative infinity
nothing happens here what happens here
if I put in some large nutbar large
negative number to substitute for that
if he's not number so correct yourself
to do if I put in either the power of
negative thousand right then negative
actually means it's on the denominator
that is an extra publicly small llama
it doesn't make sense of it a
microscopically small number okay
so therefore the limit all of the first
derivative for this part is zero which
leaves you just with r1 right so that
means to the left
side of this graph I am approaching a
gradient of one that's just our regular
sort of straight line business okay so
this is the kind of thing that's
happening it is not curving downwards at
ever-increasing steepness as what what's
doing this is where it's going it's a
person your constant of some kind
okay well that one I put it into write
down you can really see what's happening
the other way when I put the in very
very large numbers facts right once
again nothing happens to you wonders of
this guy he gets huge and he's negative
right
so that's why it drops off like a walk
so you can see I've got the steepness
happening over here you've almost got
kind of like the weed marriage between a
straight line and an exponential which
you know what shouldn't be that
surprising because that's exactly what
we have combined now this ionic says
he's what most of you have that's not
too bad I should to be me I should put
up quite a scale there what would be a
good point for scale that one I put in x
equals one welcome to cares like this if
I put in x equals one I'm gonna get one
minus e to the 1 yep that's one minus
two point seven one blah blah blah so
that is by this one point seven boat
right now the reason why I go to the end
of calculating that is because I know
where negative one is so this point the
scale about to put on it had better be
too risque oh that's the whole point
[ __ ] this girl right so that's why
negative one is cuz I want that in that
would make negative two about there so
maybe one point seven I guess would be
cooler there abouts
are you happy with that so I'm going to
call that one one - name okay that's
good that's important there's still one
more thing missing though there is an
asymptote okay now already had the
intuition to know there would be an
asset oh yeah
because this is what the grading is
doing Saperstein straight line but I
want to call your mind back to the end
of last year do you remember extension
one students I was very cruel to you and
I made you come to with some extension
two letters I said I want to teach you a
method of graphing particular kinds of
functions that even at that stage you
didn't have the calculus to deal with in
this way but there's nothing stopping
you getting a general picture that's a
composite function that's a composite
function it's made up of y equals x and
i'm going to do it by the addition of
ordinates so I choose to think of this
as X plus negative e to the X it's a
decade it's nothing flipped vertically
vertically so here he is
here's that upside down next image
and now you can see very clearly what's
going on right look at this let me do it
just by addition of limits cuz we all
did this last week
what's the easiest point to add of you
it's the zebra and the negative one
BAM I'm that right I can see maybe here
the exponential cut is vanishing away we
kind of already knew that right so then
the exponential curve is vanishing away
or you get this left with is this time
there's our asymptote right that's what
I'm approaching and then of course over
here well okay so it clearly is just
like a tug-of-war exponential is gonna
win right but it's not like this light
disappears right so even though this
wind I'm always going to stay just above
this brown so something like that okay
let's think about this so the short
answer to that question the short answer
in this context isn't them and the
reason why is look I thought was stuff
like I was I was forced to go through
double through all these hoops I had to
do the derivatives like the argument
just favorable in green lines had
nothing to do in calculus and notice I
didn't really know that there was a
stationary point there I just kind of
guessed right where is by going through
this process it's like yeah I know
there's a station but I know exactly
where it is and what's value is calculus
has to tell you that
however like what I would do like the
reason I knew to say all these things
and ask you those questions is because I
already had a rough sketch in my brain
that that's
I was going to do there's nothing wrong
with that it's a little bit like at the
moment I'm teaching um I'm taking you
seven hand around yesterday so I teach
some stuff like this they can work this
out they can go through the long steps
and get the exact answer
but then at the end I say okay now can
you just check that like let's just
round these numbers let's go towards
something round can you like don't check
it against now that's really easy to do
every single reason suit can do it at
the drop of a hat and they can know yeah
good I'm in the right ballpark I didn't
accidentally add a zero or my answer is
twice the size of that kind of clear
let's have these functions for me yeah
of course yeah that's exactly what I
expect this is exactly what I expect the
calculus sort of confirms what I was
predicting